- YouTube, I often talk
about how my mom crushed it.
You know, I talked about writing
a book called Perfectly Parented.
You're about to watch a video
that talks about that in detail.
But ultimately, I believe
the biggest miss in the world
is people focusing on
things that don't matter
and underestimating things that matter.
The story may confuse many,
but at the end of the day,
focusing on the things that matter most
and building up self esteem around that.
And then suffocating and muting
the stuff society values,
because in reality long term,
it doesn't matter as much.
That nuance, landing that plane is
what my mom did phenomenally.
Watch this.
- You're so confident
and so sure of yourself,
but when you were just
starting, who was the person?
- My mom.
- Your mom
- What'd she do for you.
- When I was nine years
old and opened the door
for an elderly woman at a McDonald's.
She reacted as if I won
the Nobel Peace Prize.
(audience laughs)
- Good mom.
- What my mom did was super-smart.
She overreacted on a
everything that I was doing,
that was a good human trait,
and she held me accountable
for things that didn't matter like grades.
My mom built huge self esteem in me,
and I feel like the biggest
reason I am who I am today
to everybody, is coz I feel so guilty,
and so grateful for what she did for me.
That I want to do it for everybody else,
which is, guess what?
You suck at a ton (alarm beeps)
Good, so does everybody else.
You're also probably pretty
(alarm beeps) rad at something.
Try as many things as
possible until you figure out
what you're rad at, and you like
and go (alarm beeps) do that
for the rest of your life
and stop giving a (alarm
beeps) on everybody else.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
- Go it.
- That was awesome.
- Thanks, cheers.
(audience applauds)